Okay, now that we have the page title and the page description, we are going to create
the H1 tag, text right here.
It's actually pretty simple because the H1 is pretty much the page title just flipped.
So we're going to put the location first and then we're going to put the services.
So just what you put here, we put concrete contractors and concrete company.
So I'm literally just going to put, so I'm going to click in it and I'm going to put
my location, which is in my case, Queen Creek, Arizona, and then you can structure this however
you like.
I think it looks clean if you put a little line there, but you can also just go ahead
and just put the keywords that we used.
So concrete contractors.
This may be too long to fit, also I'm putting that, but I usually like to use the actual
three letters and concrete company and then click out of it.
Let's see what it looks like, okay.
I do like it to be a little more bold and then just double check how it looks like from
a phone.
Yeah, that's fine.
Keep in mind, I know this sounds like silly, but we're only doing this because Google is
going to crawl our website and we're just doing the on-page SEO.
We're not doing this to make it look, because obviously this is the same thing.
Oops.
And then make sure you don't put concrete twice.
Okay, let's delete that out.
Perfect, it should look even better now.
Okay, concrete contractors and concrete company.
You may ask, well, can I just put concrete contractors and company?
No, because the keyword is concrete company, not just company.
You might as well just take out concrete company and just leave concrete contractors if it's
really bugging you.
Okay, next one, stamped concrete.
Okay, same thing.
Same thing as your page title.
Location first, so you flip the page title.
Oops, stamped concrete and decorative concrete.
Make it a little bigger.
Perfect.
Okay, concrete driveway.
I don't remember.
I think concrete installers is what we put, okay.
Queen Creek, Arizona, concrete driveway, and concrete installers.
Make it a little bigger.
Perfect.
Concrete patio.
Queen Creek, Arizona, concrete patio, and concrete walkway.
Okay, and you're done because we're not doing the contact page.
We are also going to cover the meta keywords.
So, we used to fill this section right here.
We don't do it anymore on our very latest sites, but this is up to you if you want to
do it or not.
We don't think that it's going to hurt you if you put meta keywords, but we're not sure
that it's really doing much by adding them.
So, what meta keywords are, it's very simple.
I'm just going to show you how to do it on the home page.
It's pretty much you just add in keywords from your keyword list, and you separate them
with a comma.
And it will tell you right here, separate each with a comma.
So, it would be concrete contractors.
It is just a list of keywords.
Concrete company, stamped concrete.
Make sure that when you're doing this, you're not just copying and pasting it from...
Like, don't ever copy the description for the home page and put it in the service page.
Everything needs to be authentic and made fresh for each page.
Same with the meta keywords.
Even if you're using the same keywords over and over, it doesn't matter.
Don't ever copy and paste.
Flip them, you know, switch them.
If you're writing everything fresh, you're never going to have that issue.
So, just try not to do that.
Concrete driveway and concrete patio.
Okay.
And that is it for H1 titles and meta keywords.